[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL PRYOR: Trello is a
visual collaboration tool
that helps people
create a shared
perspective on any
project, whether it's
at work or at home.
We took the whiteboard
that you might
have in your office
and the sticky note
and basically built
Trello from that.
You can plan any project you
have by using those cards
and moving them around the board
to figure out what's going on.
It's super important
for us to be everywhere
that people are
collaborating, so we
had to make sure that you had
the best possible experience
that you could have on
your Android device.
HAMID PALO: When we first
started thinking about Trello
on mobile, we were faced
with a very difficult design
problem of how to take
something that is so visual
and condense it into
a smaller screen
so you still get the same visual
overview of everything that's
happening.
FYZA HASHIM: Before Material,
Trello seem very inconsistent.
It was hard to navigate.
Material Design has
really helped the design
and development process, because
the guidelines are so thorough
and well thought out.
You don't have to go back
and forth with developers.
HAMID PALO: Our
Material redesign
has been a huge success for us.
What we have seen
is a 10% increase
in the number of sessions
per user per week,
a 42% increase in the number
of boards created per session,
and most importantly
for us, a 63% increase
in the number of users
added to boards per session.
That tells us that people
are using Trello way more
than they were using it before.
MICHAEL PRYOR: Trello is fun.
It's flexible.
There is so much that
you can do with it.
FYZA HASHIM: They can plan
out their meals for the week.
They don't have to go to the
fridge and write down a list.
It's a more natural way.
It's like you're talking to
your spouse or your boyfriend
or your girlfriend.
Instead, you're just
telling it to your watch,
and it'll put it
on the Trello list.
HAMID PALO: A key area where
Trello really, really shines
is when you use it
with somebody else.
FYZA HASHIM: Material gives you
a better way of communicating.
HAMID PALO: One of
the things that we've
seen people use Trello
for is planning marathons.
And they can plan
routes, and they can say,
I've done these
exercises and everything.
FYZA HASHIM: It
helps the user focus
on what they're doing
instead of thinking about how
they're going to do it.
HAMID PALO: If I had any
advice for developers,
isolate what is
core about your app,
and then use the Material
principles in the framework
to come up with a design
that best delivers that
to your users.
FYZA HASHIM: Work
with Google Play,
because there are so
many options out there
for developers and designers.
MICHAEL PRYOR:
After Material, we
were able to define
Trello's visual identity
and combine those
things together,
so we had a clear vision
of what Trello was.
I'm most proud of the
fact that what we've built
is loved by so many people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]